we called it the trouble and its arrival
changed us forever
you
hey everybody i'm jason jones and i want
to show you what we've been working on
here at bungie since we first introduced
destiny back in 2013
destiny is our next gen first-person
shooter where you'll explore the
abandoned ruins of an ancient human
civilization long after it has been
overtaken by our enemies the darkness is
coming back we will not survive it this
time
but there's still hope a candle in the
darkness the last safe city on earth
and at the center of the city is our
home the tower the place we return after
every adventure
to claim our rewards
to buy and sell weapons and gear
and to meet up with our friends
guardians are fighting on earth and
beyond join guardian push back the
darkness
in destiny you choose who you want to be
and who you want to become
you go out into the world to earn
powerful weapons
cool armor
and combat abilities that change the way
you fight
the choices you make say a lot about the
type of player you are in destiny
there's so many ways to upgrade your
class and perfect your style of play
as you defeat your enemies you'll
discover new places to go and uncover
more reasons to head out on new
adventures so we created the director it
answers the question what's awesome to
do right now and what's my reward for
doing it and that's important because in
destiny there's a ton of cool stuff to
do like a great story campaign where
you'll explore the mysteries of our lost
worlds well fort many guardians fell
strong ones but you made it here
don't let them find you and from the
beginning we built destiny to be played
cooperatively either match made or with
your friends
on your adventures through the world
you'll stumble on public events where
you can join up with other players on
the fly to take on huge targets of
opportunity
before returning to your journey right
where you left off
when you're ready for a little downtime
you can go off the beaten path and
explore
and when you want to team up with two
other players and fight through waves of
enemies to take down an epic boss you
head into a strike
there's so much amazing stuff to find a
destiny so many ways to combine your
class your abilities your armor and
weapons to build a guardian you want to
become and you can even take that
Guardian into the crucible our intense
competitive multiplayer
you build your character grow more
powerful as you take on greater
challenges
and maybe one day become powerful enough
to find a way inside the vault of glass
to defeat the most challenging
experience we've ever created and earned
Destiny's ultimate rewards
so that's what we've been doing here at
bungee we're having a great time playing
this game and we can't wait for you to
experience it to
should the awoke you'll never need an
ally I will call on you and expect you
to answer she saying you owe us guardian
you